[Music]
welcome to where the magic happens
you've seen this place before mostly in
the background of these a-roll shots and
in b-roll shots where i'm either wasting
time or being productive the only two
types of b-roll shots on this entire
channel but anyways today we're gonna go
over this home office setup of mine in
detail so that you guys can spend more
time on the things that fulfill you and
that will move your life forward rather
than slipping deeper and deeper into the
endless abyss of algorithmically curated
content like this video also like this
video let's jump into it the theme that
i had in mind when i was designing this
space was minimalism it's because i'm
very original and unlike any other
productivity youtuber the goal of a
productivity space should be to reduce
the friction in the way of doing the
important things that you have to do in
a day you want to make sure that
everything on your desk facilitates a
concentrated flow state because getting
into that flow state is more important
than anything in the world it's even
more important than spending quality
time with your son i think that's what
gary v told me so how do i achieve that
flow state well let's get into some
specifics the thing that i look at all
day long is my lg ultrafine 4k monitor
the thing i really like about this
monitor is that it has a usbc port on
the back so i only have one cable to
connect to my macbook pro that transfers
audio power display it really helps play
into this minimalist vibe the reason why
i went with this monitor specifically is
because it's tack sharp it wasn't too
expensive the blacks are nice and deep
and it is very color accurate so i
really enjoy editing videos on here
because i get an accurate representation
of what the image actually looks like
the monitor is connected to my daily
driver which is the 16-inch macbook pro
with the m1 max chip this is like the
premium top of the line apple device
right now it absolutely shreds 4k video
it's crazy to me that this thin slice of
metal is all i need to run a production
company that uses cutting edge 4k video
multiple layers of it and this thing
doesn't flinch the only downside is the
cost this thing costs more than i pay my
assistant jared in a year but that
actually doesn't bother me sitting right
next to it is the new amd razer blade 14
which i mostly use for gaming but
because this is a productivity channel
that was a joke i use it for programming
this beautiful sexy keyboard is the
kikron k6 i learned about this keyboard
by watching an ali abdol video where he
was going over a bunch of different
mechanical keyboards basically he was
investigating which keyboard would help
him type the fastest this keyboard
scored one of the lowest scores and he
said that the build quality wasn't
impressive at all and it kind of felt
like a toy but i thought it looked cool
so i bought it immediately and the mouse
i use is the razer deathadder 2. i came
to the decision to buy this mouse
because i was playing rust with my
brother last week and i was trying to
flick on kids with the bow and i was
just missing all my shots because i'm
at rust but naturally i blamed the
mouse and my mouse at the time was the
logitech mx master 2s but i'm starting
to realize that it's actually kind of
there's a ton of input lag which
makes it actually less accurate to use
even if you're not gaming there was a
delay between when i moved my hand and
when the mouse moved so to solve this
issue i picked up the razer deathadder
v2 and i noticed an immediate difference
this thing has basically zero
milliseconds of input lag when i move my
hand the mouse moves in perfect sync
with it even for video editing i'm way
less clumsy and i can click on things
more accurately which probably saves me
a lot of time and mental energy
subconsciously it's probably not that
big of a difference i'm not going to
pretend that changing your mouse out to
like a slightly higher refresh rate or
response time will change your
productivity forever but i'm a bit of a
snob and i do this for a living so i can
get away with spending money on things
that i don't actually need moving on so
i'm a big audio guy a lot of you guys
say your voice just sounds so crisp why
does it sound so crisp well partly it's
because of this mic i'm using i'm
probably not gonna give it a shout out
but a lot of that is because i'm a bit
of an audiophile and i maintain that the
best bang for buck speakers you can get
for under 200 if you want just like a
nice little easy thing to buy on amazon
get these edifiers i can't remember what
they're called but the link will be in
the description i've used a bunch of
different small budget-friendly studio
monitors before but i always come back
to the edifiers because i think they
just punch well above their weight on
amazon these speakers are around 150
canadian which is probably like a buck
50 us so pick them up they're very cost
effective but if you want premium sound
quality these edifiers aren't hit you're
gonna be spending you know a thousand
dollars plus on a pair of studio
monitors if you want something like
truly audiophile status but if i'm sound
mixing i'm not using my speakers anyways
i'm using my headphones and that's where
my bare dynamic dt990 pros come in these
are also budget-friendly but i've
literally never heard a better sounding
pair of headphones these things make
listening to music an absolute joy they
make mixing audio an absolute joy
everything has a certain level of
clarity and purity with these headphones
and i'm a huge fan
the only issue that might be an issue
depending on how you use them is that
when you put them on they are not
isolating so you can kind of hear
everything around you so if you work in
a busy coffee shop or a noisy
environment with a lot of ambient noises
then i wouldn't recommend these
headphones but for this very quiet
office on the top floor in a random
house in the middle of suburbia it works
great for me i run both the speakers and
the headphones through the scarlet 2i2
this is by far the least interesting
piece of tech in this whole video so i'm
just gonna move on but i like it i use
it it works to the right of my desk is
my whiteboard and there used to be a
whole bunch of stuff on here an attack
plan marketing strategy product list
video ideas we used to just fill the
board with like the entire better ideas
strategy courses that we could launch
products we could make bloody blah blah
but what ended up happening was analysis
paralysis when there was too many things
on the board we didn't really know what
to do every single day and by we i mean
jared and i jared who helps me with
videos and his desk is over there we're
not gonna we're not gonna cover his desk
i don't know how proud he is of his desk
but anyways we basically erased pretty
much everything on the whiteboard save
for a few key things that we kind of
need to remember on a day-to-day basis
and we replace it with this little box
that has the one thing it is the most
important thing we have to do each day
and we spend half an hour evaluating
what this one thing is and we pretend
that nothing else exists we don't think
about anything else until this one thing
is done and the result is that our
productivity has skyrocketed once we
have done this one thing not only do we
do the most important thing with clarity
and focus but we're more inspired to
tackle all the other that we
would have had on there so it's a
win-win and the last thing i want to
mention is my gaming setup and you might
say joey this is a productivity video
why do you keep on reverting this back
to gaming well i have a problem with
gaming and i'm really trying to work on
it but i do think there's something to
uh to learn here i just can't stop
playing video games so basically my xbox
is below my desk out of sight and out of
mind the xbox being below my desk
provides a lack of visual cue so i don't
get interrupted in the middle of being
productive and tempted to play xbox and
sweat halo infinite but i also keep my
gaming monitor at the base of this shelf
so that every time i want a game i have
to walk over to the monitor pick it up
bring it to my desk hook it up and you
might be saying joey why don't you just
hook up your xbox to the monitor that
you seem to be so high about on your
desk so that all three of your devices
are nice and streamlined and minimal but
the problem is while the display is
quite nice and it's sharp and it has
deep blacks and it's nice to look at for
color grading it's only 60 fps and i'm
not a filthy casual i stole this plant
from my sister so it makes my office set
up look more zen or some but that's
pretty much it guys i don't really know
what else to talk about in here but
hopefully you guys have a little bit of
an idea of how
i choose to operate my productivity
setup and maybe you guys got a few ideas
i don't know maybe you're just
entertained but that's pretty much it
you guys can stop asking for this type
of video unless you really liked it and
this video does really well and it gets
tons of views or something in which case
i'll just do it again a big thank you to
skillshare for sponsoring this video for
those of you who don't know skillshare
is an online learning community with
thousands of inspiring classes for
anyone who loves learning and wants to
explore their creativity and learn new
skills if 2022 is the year that you told
yourself you're going to finally learn
programming or cooking or get better at
photography then skillshare is the
perfect place to start one of my main
priorities for this year was to just
sort of organize my life top to bottom
my financial life my personal life my
professional life so that 2022 seems
just simpler i want things to be simpler
not as chaotic as they were in 2021 and
for that reason i turn to my boy thomas
frank who's the master at this kind of
thing and he has the perfect class for
me which is basically organizational
workflow for creatives so if you're a
writer a photographer a videographer or
anybody who likes to produce more than
they consume ideally then i highly
recommend this class by thomas frank
that will help you spend more time doing
the things that you love and that
fulfill you rather than consuming halo
infinite and smiling friends clips on
youtube all day and that basically sums
up skillshare in a nutshell it's always
super easy to take whatever you're
learning on skillshare and apply it
directly to your real-life pursuits
whatever those may be so if you guys
want to make 2022 a year of growth then
i highly recommend checking out
skillshare using my link in the
description below the first 1000 of you
will get one month of skillshare free so
go ahead and hit up that link learn
something new explore your creativity
and as usual have a great time if you
like this video make sure you actually
hit the like button because when you hit
the like button the algorithm goes oh
this might have actually been an above
average video and more people should
know about this type of content that
really helps me out and it potentially
helps other people out so it's just a
win-win if you actually click that
button if you're lurking here consider
subscribing and checking out the second
channel where there is more meme content
more enjoyable content
i don't know if it's more enjoyable but
it's definitely mimier and more chaotic
and also follow the brand new instagram
that we got we're kind of lacking in the
followers department but i'm going to do
a giveaway on there very soon last time
we had a giveaway we gave away a bunch
of kindles but yeah your chances of
winning are pretty high because there's
like no subscribers on there or no
followers on there um so yeah give it a
follow that's all for today thank you so
much for watching and we'll catch you in
the next video
also go outside it's probably really
nice where you are even if it's not nice
where you are go outside